la question que tout le monde se pose
quand on prend conscience de la quantité
d'antibiotiques qu'on donne aux animaux
d'élevage c est ce que tous ces
antibiotiques l'on se retrouve dans la
viande qu'on mange
la réponse est non les éleveurs doivent
se soumettre à des règles strictes qui
sont émises par santé canada qui les
oblige à cincy de donner des
antibiotiques un certain nombre de jours
avant d'envoyer les animaux à l'abattoir
on appelle ça la période de retrait ça
veut dire que les autorités de santé
publique ont calculé le nombre de jours
nécessaires entre l'arrêt du médicament
et le moment où on en voit l'animal à
l'abattoir de façon à ce que la carcasse
ne contiennent pas plus de résidus
d'antibiotiques que ce qu'un être humain
peut consommer chaque jour durant toute
une vie sans qu'il n'y ait d'effet
indésirable sur sa santé le nombre de
jours de retrait varie selon
l'antibiotique qui est employé est
l'espèce animale qui est traité parce
que certaines espèces animales élimine
plus rapidement les antibiotiques en
fonction de leur métabolisme
à titre d'exemple les éleveurs de porcs
cesse de donner des antibiotiques à
leurs animaux en moyenne de 10 à 21
jours avant les envoyer à l'abattoir
par contre dans la volaille la période
de retrait est plus courte
les éleveurs de poulets cesse de donner
des antibiotiques à leurs animaux de un
à douze jours avant les envoyer à
l'abattoir